all right people it is Super Tuesday
here in America
March 3rd 2020 a lot is happening in the
world of Elections and things of that
nature we are gonna do ladies and
gentlemen we are gonna do our first-ever
live video Skype call in show tonight
here on the Rubin report on YouTube live
that's what we're doing tonight I'll
also take text questions from you I'm
gonna share some thoughts it's been a
bananas hour for me I was at the Daily
wire at 5 o'clock till 5:20 catted with
with Clavin and Knowles and Jeremy
boring and that Shapiro guy for about 20
minutes jumped in my car drove home I
had 9 minute window and then I was just
live with Glenn Beck doing the video
thing he's obviously over in Texas we
did that for about 20 minutes my crews
pulling all sorts of stuff together Here
I am live with you guys we are doing our
first ever live Skype call and show so
look you could be watching CNN right now
you could be watching MSNBC you could be
watching whatever else there is out
there
but on those shows you're just gonna get
a bunch of depressed alcoholics who get
everything wrong every time doing it
over and over again on this show you're
gonna get a non depressed host who's not
drunk drinking water I am staying
hydrated and real people all over the
country so if you want to submit a
question either by text or by video I'm
only taking questions from people that
are part of the Rubin report community
so just go sign up at Rubin report comm
and submit a question you tell us your
Skype name we'll see what we can work
out it is Super Tuesday and a lot of
interesting things are happening before
I get to questions or some of the the
latest updates and the rest of it I
thought I would just fill you guys in on
a little bit of what my last couple days
have been like I did vote yesterday so I
went to our local voting area it was a
very unimpressive little room with a lot
of seemingly homeless people around this
is Los Angeles it's not quite as
homeless E as San Francisco but we're
getting there
I am registered as an independent so the
way it works here in California is if
you're registered as an independent when
you get there before you get to the
booth when you're checking in you can
pick which party you want to vote for so
in this case it was very obvious that I
want my ability as a citizen to affect
the outcome of the Democratic primary
more than the Republican primary right
now right because obviously Donald Trump
is going to be the Republican nominee so
I want to be able to influence the
Democratic side so I had to pick
Democratic and then I got the the list
of Democratic candidates now part of the
the silliness of early voting and I
don't hear anybody talking about this is
that we just had yesterday Peabody Judge
and Amy Klobuchar drop out of the race
but open voting early voting here in
California and I think in many of the
other states has been happening for
about ten days so that means there are
thousands and thousands of people who
voted for Klobuchar who voted for
Peabody judge who had they known they
were gonna drop out the day before Super
Tuesday might've voted for somebody else
now koba char and Buddha judge have now
both endorsed by Dhin so maybe those
people would have vote voted for Biden
maybe they would have voted for nobody
maybe they would have voted for Sanders
who knows but it just does show you all
the machinations in the game that is
politics right because it's like what's
really going on here I don't think it
takes a genius to put the pieces
together is that finally whatever is
left of the moderates of the Democratic
Party and I'm not even sure that there
are any moderates left finally they're
coalescing around Biden to say we've got
to stop the socialist insurgency because
the the the simple truth the
uncomfortable truth is that the
Democrats have a parasite in the host
right the host is the democratic party
that that party has a platform and that
party is supposed to have some sort of
cohesive set of views and then the
Socialists came in and the progressives
snuck in with with the Socialists and
they're taken down the entire party and
there's a lot of energy amongst young
people for that and as I've been saying
for a couple weeks now if not a couple
months I don't think the Democratic
Party survives this thing the the ideas
of the Bernie
sandir socialists are so counter to
whatever decent ideas the the remaining
democrats have whatever those ideas are
because it's actually very unclear what
cohesive ideas Biden and Buddha judge
and Klobuchar are let's say the more
moderates have but they're not
socialists and that's why everyone
suddenly was like holy cow these last
two weeks it really seems like Bernie's
gonna get away with it or steal this
thing from our party and he's not a
Democrat he is a socialist he calls
himself a Democratic Socialist but as
I've said for a long time
he's just hanging the word Democrat for
a while and then once socialist becomes
cool enough he'll drop that word so
they're finally saying we're standing up
to the socialist but I don't think the
party can stop this thing I see and what
probably should happen at this point is
let these two groups of people go a
different way let the Socialists and the
progressives have their giant government
do everything for you take from
everybody and give to whoever you want
to give to let them have that party and
let the remaining Democrats have
whatever whatever it is they stand for
and again I'm just not sure what they
stand for at this point and then let the
Republicans have their own party I do
want to bring up something interesting
because it's come up a couple of times I
just discussed this with Glenn Beck is
that on the right you could say well
what do you mean on the right they've
got their own divisions - right they've
got libertarians they've got
conservatives they've got some classical
liberals whatever it is but those things
if you think back to 2016 try to
remember the primaries and during the
primaries he had Ted Cruz he was against
Trump and yet Marco Rubio and he was
against Trump and yet Trump was it you
had chris Christie and a whole bunch of
other people now they were all arguing
about things but they kind of in many
cases we're really arguing about
personality right it was like oh don't
vote for Trump because of his
personality but the basic idea is that
they all are capitalists they all talk
about the Constitution freedom liberty
states rights they're all mostly I think
all of them actually are pro-life now
you may not be pro-life but there's a
cohesive set of ideas there and then
there's different personalities within
that there's different tactics within
that but what has happened on the left
is there is no unifying principle
anymore so the unifying principle of the
right is the Constitution right is that
these people basically want to be
governed by the Constitution
they want individual rights they believe
in capitalism what is that on the left
anymore I don't think anybody knows so
the only way to fully under thing I
think would be for the Socialists to
have the party and the Democrats have
the party there's a whole bunch of weird
things happening right now so they're
coalescing around Biden who at I think
77 years old this is the sad
uncomfortable truth that nobody in the
mainstream media wants to touch is
obviously having cognitive problems that
is sad it's unfortunate I'm pretty sure
everybody watching this has either seen
a great grandparent or a grandparent or
a parent go through this I just did a
show actually this morning with max
Luger Beer who wrote a book called
genius foods and his new book is genius
life whose mom got alzheimer's disease
at 58 years old that's what got him into
this whole thing in the first place so
we talked about degenerative diseases
like this and cognitive issues so this
is deeply sad I would say in depressing
what seemingly is happening to Joe Biden
right now but the party's going oh he's
the guy to coalesce around as the last
thing to stop the socialists and I think
what the really scary part of this is
and by the way I think Joe Biden is
probably a pretty decent guy I think he
actually loves America I actually think
you know he said the word Constitution
in one of their debates they never say
it tulsi gabbard does talk about the
Constitution occasionally but try to
imagine Elizabeth Warren or Bernie
Sanders saying something positive about
the Constitution they can try to imagine
them invoking the Bill of Rights they
can write all their policies are
actually in complete opposition to our
founding documents actually so the real
issue here is that they're coalescing
around a guy that there is no reason to
think not only that he can make it to
the election just cognitively but then
lead the country for four years I mean
this is it this is a huge deeply
uncomfortable problem that they're gonna
have to grapple with but it's not just
them that are gonna have to grapple with
it it's everyone who considers themself
a Democrat or a lefty if you're voting
for Joe Biden you have to strongly
strongly consider that you're actually
not voting for four years of Joe Biden
you're voting forever whoever the vice
president is so you know every time an
election rolls around it's like the Vice
President can cause a little pomp or
controversy I mean remember Sarah Palin
and John McCain but it's like you know
we have Dan Quayle with George HW Bush
and there's been some strange choices
over the years or it was like you know
we had Dick Cheney who many people
thought was running the country more
than W Bush but what this really comes
down to is in a very different way than
has happened at least in the last 50
some-odd years is that if you vote for
Joe Biden you really have to think
you're voting for the the vice president
you have to really take that into
account and by the way Bernie Sanders is
a year older than Joe Biden and had a
heart attack within the last six months
so it's somehow the two old white
millionaires that's what the that's what
the Democrats got left with which you
know I mean make of that make that of
make of that what you will
I guess Warren's still in it but she'll
be out soon she's just trying to figure
out what she can extract that a Bernie
for an endorsement or something like
that but look if Bernie is able to
extract the VP position it won't be
Bernie but if he's able to extract the
VP position out of Biden to say I'm not
gonna have my my foot soldiers burned
down the party in Milwaukee so you got
to take a OC or you got to take stacey
abrams or one of the people who will
just do my bidding well then you really
should know as a Democrat you're voting
for a socialist because Biden can't do
this I mean I think that's just it's
just sad and obvious it's just sad and
obvious so we're in a really weird spot
all that being said from the numbers I'm
looking at and they're showing me some
stuff live right now
Biden's having a pretty good night
Bernie is doing sort of where everyone
expected and I would say Ann Bloomberg
is just a total bust I mean Bloomberg
has no personality nobody likes the
billionaire coming and trying to buy the
thing did you guys see the video of him
licking his fingers today at the after
he eats pizza and many touches the
coffee thing and it's like what is this
this guy is so out of touch he has no
personality I think he's probably a
decent guy and I think he's probably a
functioning executive and I voted for
him for mayor at least once when I lived
in New York City and I think he knows
how to run things but man this is just
what a terrible candidate terrible
debater no personality no nothing so
okay so here's what we're gonna do guys
I'm gonna take some of your Skype calls
you guys have also been texting in
things these are all for people that are
part of the Rubin report
unity which you can join for free at
Rubin report dot come and we're gonna
talk to you guys
actual real human beings we're gonna see
what happens when when real human beings
make it on YouTube pretty crazy but I'm
gonna do a couple text questions first
and then and then we'll go from there
with candidates dropping out and
coalescing behind Joe Biden to Bernie
Sanders voters start to feel like the
DNC dislikes him as much as Trump yeah
the DNC you got to remember the DNC is a
party is a political party which means
it has a set of views that known as the
party platform and these are the ideas
that they want to get out there this is
what I was saying before bernie is
saying I'm a socialist I'm coming into
your party and taking over so the party
has it well within there right you know
people were saying oh well they're gonna
steal the election from Bernie now if
Bernie had got to the convention and
gotten enough delegates by their rules
by the party's rules if he had gotten
enough delegates to just be the nominee
and then they took the nomination away
from him that would be stealing it but
if he doesn't get the hit the threshold
of Delegates that he needs to
automatically trigger the nomination
well then they have a brokered
convention and that's why the Democrats
have super-delegates so you may not like
the idea of super-delegates and that's
fine and you may think it's a corrupt
way of doing it and that's fine too
but if the party then goes ok we got to
the convention Bernie's winning
potentially even by a lot although now
it doesn't look like that's gonna happen
but Bernie has a nice chunk here he's
beating Biden let's just say it's by a
little bit doesn't matter how much it's
by the super-delegates can come in and
make the final decision that's how the
party operates and again you don't have
to like those rules you don't have to
like their system but that's how it is
and it would be it would be I would say
it would be self-preservation for the
party at that point to say all right our
rabid young base of socialists wanted
one thing but we don't view that to be a
functional positive future for our party
because we don't think socialism really
sells in America and that ultimately in
the in the election Trump will be able
to just scream see this guy hates
America and I love America and we're
gonna and then they'll just be a wipe
out of the Socialist Left which by the
way is exactly what happened with Corbin
in the you
Hey so the party can do whatever it sees
fit to survive as a party which is why
I'm saying Bernie if you don't like it
and you don't like the super-delegates
then leave create your own party so I do
think that's the ultimate end of where
this gets with the with the Democrats
right now I'm gonna do one more and then
we'll we will jump to your video cause
we'll start taking video closed by the
way it looks like Warren's just doing
pretty crappy tonight so at the moment
if I'm looking at this as of as of seven
minutes ago right now the the delegate
count is this Joe Biden now has a
hundred thirty eight delegates Bernie
Sanders has ninety Budaj Edge has twenty
six Warren has nine and let's let's
forget the rest
so Biden is now the serious frontrunner
and you're gonna see the media back him
more you're gonna see the other
Democrats come out the interesting piece
of this is where is Barack Obama where
is Hillary Clinton right where are the
real power people of the party are they
still worried were they waiting for this
to happen today I mean I suspect it
seems to me if you're Barack Obama
you've been kind of playing the fence
both sides here right like you know that
the progressives are the future of this
thing whether you like it or not so you
didn't want to back bite and early
because if he flamed out you'd look
pretty stupid but at this point it's
like if everybody's going bite and
regardless of what your concerns are or
the cognitive stuff or whatever else
it's like the wise it seems to me I
guess at that point if that's your line
into thinking the wise thing for Obama
tomorrow would be like all right Biden's
firmly in the lead this is my guy he was
the VP should have come around a little
earlier but I wanted him to do it on his
own and and here we are and then and
something similar for Hillary but I'm
telling you guys I just think that the
rules are so out of whack right now and
I think that the Selective pressure is
related to the cognitive stuff and the
socialist stuff I think everything is in
such flux right now that I think it's
there's like a 25% chance that Hillary
could somehow get back in or the party
leaders select her like this whole thing
is seriously seriously a mess and for
some reason the mainstream media refuses
to have an honest conversation about it
which also then creates what I called on
Twitter yesterday's sort of the great
truth divide which is that if you are
paying a ten
to YouTube and podcasts and Twitter
we're all seeing certain things so the
Biden gaps is interesting because if you
watch CNN you never see the Biden gaps
right when he can't remember where he is
or he says he's in North South Dakota or
this that the other thing and all of
these things you never never see them on
mainstream media but if you live online
like most younger people do and actually
most even people in their 30s 40s 50s
and maybe into their 60s and above do at
this point you start seeing this stuff
right because it gets out there on
Instagram it gets out there on Twitter
but then we have a truth divide because
people are watching CNN going oh Biden
gave another great speech and the media
seems to like him and the Democrats like
him and then the online people are going
did you see this did you see this forgot
what state he's in can't remember this
said 170 million people were killed by
guns as he said at the the debate last
week all this stuff and it's like man
then you then these two people these two
groups they can't sort of come together
and and say this is actually true what
is happening here so we got we got a
series of problems right now related to
national discourse I've been trying to
clean up a little bit of it I think
we're doing okay here
Texas is a really interesting one what
I'm seeing right now is that Sanders is
at 28.8% and Biden's at 22.3 now the
Democrats do this by proportion so if
you win by five percent you're only
getting the proportion in terms of
Delegates so it does it's not a
winner-take-all thing right those are
the Republicans do winner-take-all
which as Shapiro was just laying out
when I was on The Daily wire about an
hour ago one of the things that really
helped Trump was he won a lot of early
states and you win them fully you get
all the delegates and then it feels like
you have this endless momentum where
with the Democrats it's a little harder
to get full full on momentum anyway so
the the delegate count right now is 138
Biden 90 Sanders 26 boo to judge forget
that and 9 Elizabeth Warren I will say
one other thing and then we're gonna
take our first call from you the good
people of the United States of America I
will say this that you know this idea
which I touched on a moment ago that
think how pissed you would be if you
voted early in one of these states and
you really were for Amy Klobuchar you
really for Pete Budaj
I read
something today the Peabody judge was
about to close his highest round of
fundraising his highest quarter of
fundraising so far it's like people
believed in these people but then the
nature of politics is such that the
party leaders get together everyone gets
together they talk it out and they're
like who knows what level of pressure
was applied to Pete where it's like Pete
yeah you think you're doing fine but
you're not this isn't your year man with
the super-delegates ain't gonna help you
at the end so if you want a future in
this party right Pete you're young you
want to get back in this thing in four
years you're gonna back by it and now
now who knows you know Koli they said
the kobish are you want to be Attorney
General right in an in a Biden
administration get out now cuz you wait
two days we're not letting you get it
because they know that those voters most
likely go to buy it and not to Sanders
so everyone has to remember there's so
many backdoor deals here by the way I
don't think any of that in and of itself
is corruption I don't even think any of
that in and of itself is is bad I mean
this is this is just the nature of
reality people try to extract things
from other people you negotiate you all
do these things but I just think for the
people that that come into politics sort
of wide-eyed and bushy tailed and you're
supporting these guys and then you vote
for them three days early and then they
drop out the day before the big prize
which is today's Super Tuesday it's just
pretty depressing and that's one of the
things that that dis affects young
voters so there's a lot of interesting
things at play all right guys we're
gonna do our first ever live Skype call
in show and who we're gonna go to first
why don't we go to Tanner
let's talk Tanner what do you got for me
my friend
hello chatter how are you
great day and how are you doing good
dude you are the first-ever live Skype
caller on the Rubin report wow that's
terrific yeah okay yet can you turn your
camera on is it on now I they'll tell me
in just a second is your camera there
you go there you are oh very nice right
nice headphones hold good setup no
backlight I'm very impressed yeah I had
had to look it up how are you doing I'm
good man so cool what's on your mind on
this Super Tuesday um I I'm pretty
impressed honestly I'm originally from
Virginia actually and was very surprised
that Biden's actually pulling it out
which kind of blew my mind
really late momentum there I guess but
Texas is a very surprising with Bernie
having such an advantage there and I'm
just trying to wonder that's like there
could be some sort of momentum out of
that with California as well just
letting that as well and those are the
two big states right just trying to
think out loud here and you know trying
to see how this is all playing out
because I think it is gonna be close at
the end of the night yeah I think it's
gonna be pretty close it'll be
interesting to see what happens in
California cuz that's obviously the
that's the big hall right that's the big
one here and as I just said I'm
registered as an independent but I went
out there and voted for Biden today just
to stop the Sanders thing what do you
think can I ask you how old you are I'm
27
so you're 27 so you're a young guy what
do you make of what's going on with the
sort of young sort of energy that it
seems like the Socialists have do you
think that's real I coming just out of
college I guess um yeah it's kind of
bananas but it there's definitely some
sort of feeling about it at least the
people that I like hang out with and
talk to like in terms of political
discourse and you know and actually can
actually have you know a nice
conversation the next day you know that
there are a lot of people like that but
I feel like social media it's like
easier to post about the social stuff
the left-wing stuff the progressive
ideology xand
and I feel like that's kind of shifted
to the front of it which is why it seems
like there's a lot of people is because
those are the more favorable positions
online they get more likes and things
like that Twitter moves it to the top
and whatever where where would you say
you shake out politically um I am
conservative I did not vote for Trump in
2016 I was a never Trump er I am
actually planning about for Trump in
2020 I see a lot of that I see a lot of
people that are that were either never
Trump errs or that were Democrats that
are just like I can't take this and if
it's my only choice I'll do it yeah
seriously it's that or Biden who bless
his heart I mean he is struggling and
Sanders who you know wants to tack all
the billionaires and and rough it out
and change up our economy it's like it's
things are going pretty well I mean I
mean they're pretty good right now
so yeah better than America not that I
visit us that's for sure right on man
well I appreciate you calling and thanks
for being the first ever you can put
this on a business card now you were the
first ever live Reuben report calling
guest on Super Tuesday 2020 it's it's a
terrific honor
awesome man and I really appreciate the
support thanks a lot yeah great take
care okay have a great rest of night all
right cool you too thanks all right see
ya all right people
that was our first ever live call I
think we're gonna do more of this I like
it I like it talking to real people
instead of turn on CNN right now if
you're watching at your computer throw
your TV on they got a box there are 27
people in the box every one of them got
everything wrong they're all giving you
the usual nonsense talking points they
all have campaign officials who all were
working on other campaigns who are now
supporting other campaigns it's just a
big freakin cyclone of stupidity we're
talking to real people over here on the
Rubin report ladies and gentlemen Oh
Tulsi Gabbard has won her first delegate
all right there you go very nice okay
I'm going to do a couple
questions via email that we got and then
we'll jump on and we'll do some more
reminder guys if you want to talk to me
you can talk to me live real people here
on the Rubin report not robotic pundits
just jump on to Rubin report com sign up
you can submit a question you'll see all
the instructions on how you go about
doing it there and we'll talk to you
guys tonight and see what's going on
this is a great question do you think
any of the candidates that dropped out
have been promised the VP seat so I
don't think anyone that just dropped out
so if you look at the just dropped out
crew right you're basically looking at
Budaj edge and clove bechara is the just
dropped out but let's even take that
further back and you could look at any
of the people that drive you know steyr
was a couple days ago you can look at
Kamala Harris you can look at Cory
Booker etc I don't think anyone's been
promised anything other than guys we're
all coming around on old Joe and if
you'll want in on the party after if you
want to stop Sanders number one look at
it look at a guy like butta Jed
right young well-spoken he comes off as
a robot to me I don't particularly like
the guy let's not forget that Budaj edge
i had tweeted once at his campaign
manager to have him on the show the guy
immediately tweeted back said yeah let's
do it
and then HuffPo Vox Media Matters all
the usual suspects they all started
attacking him on Twitter and we had
already started the logistical
conversation behind the scenes on how to
get him on the show and they just
stopped responding to us and the the
communications manager for blue de jedge
unfollowed me on Twitter so this is not
a guy I have a great amount of respect
for not that he had anything to do that
specifically but he obviously has hired
people that bow to the mob but he's a
guy that obviously has a future in the
Democratic primary right like he's a
little Obama clone you probably saw that
video of him and Obama just saying the
exact same things with the exact same
intonation they put the videos side by
side it's something else so they go the
party leaders say to Booty judge alright
Pete mayor Pete you want a future in
this thing well drop out now before
Super Tuesday because we're all doing
this we're all getting around old Joe
and maybe you'll be VP maybe you'll be
in the cabinet maybe you'll be this
maybe you'll be that who knows what's
going on Klobuchar I mean I think her as
Attorney General would kind of make
sense hey Amy we're all doing this you
want the Attorney General gig
there's all sorts of players like that
but again
whoever Biden selects as VP you have to
view that as as the presidential
candidate I just it's sad it's sad we
all know it and mainstream refuses to
acknowledge it that the Democrats right
now are coalescing around a 77 year old
man who's a year younger than Bernie
Sanders who had a heart attack six
months ago who is having cognitive
problems that is just the truth
it is the sick twisted bizarro truth
that we find ourselves having at 20/20
but but here we are so I don't think
anyone's been promised VP but I do think
this is the most important VP position
that you could possibly imagine at this
point because in effect you're voting
for the President of the United States
let's see can you convince right-leaning
people that they don't have Bernie
derangement syndrome maybe Bernie and
the checks and balances will create a
cool Singaporean USA that's a really
interesting question because I've never
been asked that before and obviously I
hit Bernie pretty hard so Trump
derangement syndrome which is the other
version of this is basically these
people that think Trump is starting
World War three Trump is Hitler his
supporters are Nazis evil is here
they're coming fascism etc etc and none
of those things are happening you know
you may not like the way he's done tax
cuts you may not like that he's cut some
regulation you may not like but he got
out of the Paris Accords or that we
ended the Iran agreement or any of these
things but none of the endless plethora
of insane things remember net neutrality
was gonna kill us we killed the Iranian
general Soleimani they said World War
three was gonna start all of these
things none of these things have come to
fruition right I mean he's governed
basically as a pretty centrist
Republican president a sort of Reagan
ish centrist you know center-right
Republican but Trump derangement
syndrome is these people that no matter
what he does you can get people to say
one thing you know something that they
said three years ago one way they can
get you can get them to say it
completely the opposite because it's
Trump not because they had a political
evolution or think about things
differently but it's because Trump said
something so now I got to believe the
opposite and you see this you see this
with a gajillion
blue check celebrities and journalists
and
Twitter people all the time so is there
a version of that that is related to
Bernie so like a Bernie derangement
syndrome look I hit Bernie all the time
I think the ideas of socialism the ideas
of collectivism are terrible I think the
idea the fundamental idea that other
people have to bow to you and that the
state should decide who we should take
more from and who we should give to I
think it crushes the human spirit I
think the ideas of collectivism have
killed more people than any other set of
ideas the basic ideas of capitalism have
brought more people out of poverty than
any other system there is is it a
perfect system probably not but guess
what humans ain't perfect so we can't
build a perfect system it's a pretty
freakin good system so when I think when
people raise the alarm about Bernie it's
not that I think Bernie Sanders himself
is evil I think he is an old socialist
with really bad ideas but what he has
done is he has caused those bad ideas to
proliferate throughout the system and
and now caused a group of young people
to think these are good ideas even
though they're time-tested as horrible
ideas and you asked socialists well
where is it worked and you know they'll
tell you if Bernie really loves Sweden
and he really loves Denmark and it's
like he loves these tiny tiny countries
that in no way are comparable to the
United States and when you tell well
what do you say well what about
Venezuela people that wasn't really
socialism socialism has never really
happened yet it's all nonsense these
these ideas of socialism are
antithetical to the human experience
which is fighting for what's yours I
want to state that basically what it
does is protect my freedoms it protects
my ability to have Liberty to have to
live the life that I want to live that's
what most people want that's why people
still want to come to America that's why
nobody wants to leave America so when
you say Bernie derangement syndrome I
think there is truly truly something to
worry about here as I said he's a
parasite in the Democratic party system
but that that party once that thing has
been taken over well then that starts
taking over the wider American system
are there ways that we could do things a
little bit
that might be more in line with what
Bernie thinks so like everybody having
health insurance if you can show me a
plan that actually allows some
competition in the marketplace and
allows people to have private health
care and all of those things of course
there's ways to do it I would still want
more to be done by charity I would still
want more to be done by good you know
this is where you see these ridiculous
people like Tom Styer he's screaming
about reparations he's really for
reparations he keeps telling us that
he's a billionaire how much is he is he
just wandering around giving black
people money of course not these people
want to outsource all the decisions to a
government that they that they believe
is good but at the same time they'll
tell you that the government's run by
Hitler so none of it makes sense
government's evil make government bigger
it's like guys let's get a cohesive set
of ideas here and that's why I think
broadly on the right individual rights
in the Constitution that that's sort of
the kernel and then from things grow
from that doesn't mean they do things
right all the time the right even the
libertarian right they always spend more
money right it's like you should be
cutting back government all the time cut
cut cut cut cut more power to the states
et cetera et cetera
the example I always use right here in
California I live in Los Angeles I've
lived here for a couple years we have
had progressive after progressive after
progressive we're getting a more
homelessness it's dirty or our streets
are crappy I was just in San Francisco
last week and it's an absolute disaster
I kid you not
I saw people shooting up heroin I assume
that was heroin I didn't walk over and
ask on the street I mean the homeless
populations garbage everywhere San
Francisco's disgusting it's another
progressive utopia why do these ideas
always fail but then you go to cities
like Dallas and you go to cities like
Salt Lake City and they're beautiful and
they're clean and the economy is good
and businesses are thriving because
they've cut taxes and they've been sent
avise Dworkin's are obvious but all the
ideas of socialism and the Bernie stuff
free college for everybody it's like
it's not really free and why do you also
want it it's not just cuz you're so nice
and you want people to be educated you
want them to be indoctrinated if you
ever wanted to send a young person to a
place to be indoctrinated into leftism
where would you send them you'd send
them to college because they've all
become bastions of leftist group think
we all know this right so these people
are they're not good and I think they
prey
useful idiots basically and and you know
also what's that line it's like if
you're not a they say if you're not a
liberal in your 20s you have no heart
and if you're not a conservative in your
30s you have no brain so it's not
exactly right but it's it's the sort of
right idea and and also you know a
really interesting thing that I've been
thinking about a lot lately
is that the last remaining good liberals
whoever they are you know I've had a
whole bunch of them in the studio you
may notice that a lot of them have gone
just radio silent on politics because
they don't know what to do anymore
because they don't want by it they know
it's not gonna work with buy it and they
don't want socialism I actually think
probably there's a lot of undercurrent
of Trump support because they're just
like he's not all of those things he's
he's he is what he is so we're in a
really weird spot but I don't think
Bernie derangement syndrome is quite the
I don't think it's quite comparable
let's say to a Trump derangement
syndrome because the Trump stuff was all
over the top he's Hitler he's a Nazi
he's gonna kill people and all of this
stuff where the Bernie stuff is like
these are legitimate the ideas that he's
bringing to the table are the worst
political ideas that have been
repackaged into something with with a
that sort of sounds right if you're not
really thinking so so it's a little bit
different alright let's see we'll do
another Skype call in just a sec so
we're doing Skype calls with you good
people go to Rubin report com sign up we
can jump on skype I'll do one more
question on that was submitted not on
video via text I'm in California and I
abstained from voting I would have only
voted for Tulsi or Amy Klobuchar anyway
do you honestly think I should have
voted um you know I've heard versions of
this Michael malleus who I think is a
great political thinker who I've had in
here many times you know he just wrote a
piece on why you shouldn't vote you know
basically don't play take part in a
rigged the game I do still think it's
your civic duty to vote if we're all
doing this right if we're all caring
about this stuff if the system still
functions at any level I think you have
to do whatever you can to be part of the
system which is why I voted which is why
I voted I have a registered independent
but I went in and I could have at that
moment said
screw the Democrats I'm tifford today
I'm a Republican and and voted for Trump
but obviously Trump was gonna you know I
don't even know if he has an opposition
candidate actually at least on the
ballot here in California I felt that
the one tiny teeny tiny thing that I
could do that would be somehow congruent
with my beliefs would be if I could help
Biden in this weird way right because I
really think Bernie is the real threat
to freedom so if my one little vote in
California and a whole bunch of other
people say I really don't like Bernie so
I'll vote for Biden even though all that
being said all the crazy things that
I've just told you about Biden why
that's a huge risk - that was the little
piece that I could do in this and I
think you got it you got to be part of
the system like otherwise you could just
complain about it you could just
complain about it or you can do what the
Bernie people are gonna do at the end of
this which is try to burn the whole
thing down I mean the the convention in
Milwaukee is gonna be an absolute
disaster they've been telling us for
months if you're paying attention that
they believe in political violence when
I was on The Young Turks off the camera
people would talk about that they
believed in a certain amount of
political violence this is what this is
what they believe that's what they're
telling you I do not believe in
political violence okay I don't I
believe we have to AB certain we have to
have a certain set of laws that we abide
by that that enable us to agree to
disagree that enable a system to exist
but as people to judge just said a
couple days ago Bernie Sanders wants to
burn it all down so in Pete's mind as a
calculating person he said okay I'm
looking at the path I don't fully see
the path the party's going around Joe
I'm in on Joe and let's see what reward
I can get at the end of it let's see
what cookie I can get at the end of this
all right
the delegate couch looks to be the same
last I just saw it here Texas
Sanders has opened up a little more of a
lead now remember this is proportional
in terms of Delegates so he's at about
twenty eight point eight this is as of a
minute ago and Biden's at twenty two
point two Bloomberg's at eighteen point
seven I mean one of the really
interesting things right now is what a
what is Bloomberg doing what is he
thinking and what does he do after this
he has the money to keep going so do you
just keep going and keep going and keep
going for what on the hopes that Biden
rumbles right because it's not like the
Sanders people might go to you if
anything you're siphoning votes away
from Biden now so it seems like if if
Bloomberg thinks that Biden can make it
that Bloomberg then would dip out now
and just fund the hell out of Biden that
that seems like would be the same thing
right if that if you're saying this we
want this again centrist but it's not
really centrist Democratic Party well
then that's what you would do
I see no use for Bloomberg staying in
unless he just thinks Biden can't make
it and you're gonna get as close as you
can in the delegate count you go for
some three-way thing where you're you're
the least favorable but then the
delegates are just like oh look it by it
and this isn't gonna work we hate
Sanders we'll take the billionaire
because at least he's got the money to
fight Trump so we'll get a new a
delegate update in just a sec let's take
a Skype call I believe we're talking to
Truman Truman how are you my friend I
love it stayin true but if if you're
there throw your video on I'm not seeing
you but no we're not seeing it all right
what we got we got audio for now got it
it's on my end
all right all right we're doing it
old-school we're going radio style what
are your thoughts on tonight well first
off thanks thanks for doing this man
this is super cool this is all yeah
awesome what you're doing locals so I
mean that's it's amazing thanks man so
I'm gonna ask you about so I mean you
might have already answered it but the
question that I had about is Bernie an
aberration or is he the logical
conclusion
I mean you so you said you know just a
few minutes ago is the parasite that's
infiltrated in there and so I'd like to
tease that out a little bit man I mean
in what way which parts of it are in
aberration so whenever he's what I mean
by that is whenever amy klobuchar says
Bernie
are you out you can't show your receipts
she's not attacking the underlying
ideology no she was one of the most
critical out there during the debates
she was just saying you don't know we
don't know how you're gonna pay for it
in other words if you could pay for
right be fine a great idea and so I'm
not sure this is something I'm trying to
figure out still but whenever he says
you know Noam Chomsky just recently said
you know Burt Bernie Sanders he would be
he would make sense to a lot of
politicians of early progressives in
what ways he a parricide what way is
that a parasite because how do you make
a distinction between Medicare for all
who want it and Medicare for all this is
this is a great question there there's
so much here then and this is the type
of thing you would never hear on CNN so
you're so right so when when Klobuchar
says oh you don't know how to pay for it
or show me the receipts or how's this
thing gonna work that's not really
saying that his ideas are bad it's like
if you could pay for your ideas your
ideas would be fine so what I would say
to that is a when Bernie says he can't
pay for things that is actually a
feature not a bug
the Socialists they don't view your
ability to pay for something as
something that would be good they view
Oh something is good healthcare for
everybody regardless of quality of care
or the other real world problems that
come along with it
they believe that the end point is good
and you got to get there no matter what
and I think really what you're asking is
is all of this and correct me if I'm
wrong I think what you're really asking
is is socialism or giant government or
progressivism collectivism whatever you
want to call it is that sort of the end
of what liberalism will become is that
is that basically what the question is
kind of um maybe so on the surface if
we're talking about polyps the politics
part sure that would be part of it
but if we talk about politics its
downstream from culture and we've
noticed I mean or you can tell me if you
think this is right or not but that all
of the framing listen to a OC talk
listen to Bernie talk and then now how
the other candidates argue for stuff
it's all using this language of morality
of justice
things aren't graded in terms of
efficacy and so right now you have this
that you know kind of the justification
for these policies is there they're just
their moral it's what they hope to do
not their actual outcomes and so as a
result of basing your policies basing
your arguments for your policies more
importantly on that is that the natural
conclusion is until they get back to you
at some point some argument through
efficacy and you know this is this is
such a good question about sort of the
underbelly of liberalism which is
something that I've been thinking a lot
about and and a good portion of my book
is devoted to this because there's a
reason that Bernie and the Socialists
and the government can do everything
people they went in through the Liberals
they went in through the lefties because
they know that liberals generally are
open-minded generally want to help
people and often unfortunately don't
think all of those things through well
enough so it's like oh you want to help
poor people tax rich people give poor
people money now we know that these
programs never work which is really I
think what you're getting to hear but
they've all accepted that the morality
of doing these things is right no matter
what and if you could just pay for it it
would be okay even though there's no
amount of money that solves homelessness
truly there's no amount of money that
solves inequality truly and also is it
right to actually just take from whoever
you want to take so you know what I need
to do more shows on this and I'll talk
about this this is this is one of the
chapters in my book is very much devoted
to this and I'll talk about this on the
tour well we shall see
got anything else for me before I let
you go
uh I'm not not other than I'm really
excited to see you when you come to
Denver in May man it's gonna be awesome
well let's uh you know what guys let's
make sure that Truman has a free
meet-and-greet for the for the show I
want to shake your hand
Thanks all right thanks a lot man all
right real people people real people on
the Rubin report Texas numbers have
shifted just a tad looks about the same
28 point for Sanders twenty eight twenty
two point eight by ten eighteen seven
four for Bloomberg that's with only 31
percent in but you can start seeing
trends that makes sense at that point
okay let me jump to to another question
via electronic message
let's see Dave is politics going forward
always going to be insane with the only
options being Sanders and Trump types
what are some meaningful changes to the
primary system that could be made such
as ranked based voting that could make
our candidates be more representative
are int of our entire party or parties
do you think a platform the size of
Twitter should be prevented from banning
political candidates on the basis of
in-kind contribution to their opponents
so I'll deal with the the tech part of
this first look you guys know I don't
want the government regulating big tech
it is it is antithetical to what my
beliefs are now the part where this
becomes messy is that a we know that the
big tech companies have all sorts of
connections with politicians we know
that most of the people in San Francisco
even though there should be libertarians
because they create things and want to
be free and want to in innovate and get
the government out of the way and do all
sorts of awesome things like create
something like uber that breaks the the
stranglehold that the taxi companies
have and do so many cool things that we
all love right I don't like the idea of
because these companies have so much
power this is the unique time where we
must give the other thing with awesome
power in this case the government the
power to link these two things together
that that really seems like a bad idea
and if you're a right-leaning person and
you're going well Trump needs to
regulate them well what happens if Trump
is out in a year from now and now you've
got president Bernie Sanders with the
power to tell
Twitter what to do I mean do you think
when when president Sanders tweets and
then right-wing people say all the awful
things that left-wing people say about
Trump every day every time Trump tweets
you think they're gonna let them on the
platform of course they wouldn't write
Trump yeah I don't know what pressure
he's applying to these companies maybe
he's doing it behind the scenes but we
don't really see it although it sounds
like this guy Paul singer who's been a
big Republican donor although I guess he
doesn't like Trump it sounds like he's
buying a huge portion of Twitter and
gonna try to force out jack so you know
they got to be deleting a lot of
documents on censoring conservatives and
shadow banning and the rest of it so
we'll find out about that so I would not
be for the in kind contribution thing
and forcing these companies to do
anything it's I know it's crappy it
doesn't feel right it doesn't feel right
the same way that when I say that I
don't want to force the Baker to bake
the cake for the gay wedding it doesn't
feel right it's like oh yeah we should
just kind of force him to do it do what
you think is the right thing or whatever
but I want people to live the lives that
they want and the only way you can do
that is staying out of people's lives
not getting involved in everybody's life
so that's that's just what I believe add
to the second or two the first part of
your question which I'm answering second
do we ever get out of this thing I
actually do think we can get out of this
thing at some level not not at every
level because everything's changing
right now the internet we are now 20 30
years into like sort of the bigger
internet were 15 20 years into social
media from Friendster to myspace to
Facebook to Twitter to blah blah blah I
think we are now facing a time when
there are all sorts of challenges we all
get our news in different places we
cater things to ourselves we're hearing
new information we're hearing false
information we're hearing ideas that are
good ideas for the first time that maybe
we didn't get taught in college that
maybe we didn't hear in the news there's
so much there right there's so much
there that we have to figure out what
does that mean to a functioning country
a functioning society that's a
pluralistic society with different
people and different ideas going forward
we have to figure that out all that
being said I do think there's a way out
of this the way out of this basically is
that the Democratic Party needs to end
thing they need to split let them split
you can't keep doing this thing where
the Socialists and the Liberals or
whatever they are at this point they're
not they're not liberals in my sense of
liberal but the Socialists and the
lefties or the old Democrats they're
they shouldn't be in the same party let
the party split let's have a more
functioning three party system which in
many ways is also scary right the more
times we split parties then we could
have all sorts of problems getting
governing coalition's that make sense
look look what's happening in Israel
just today they had their third election
I think within the last like fourteen
months or so and once again Netanyahu
has the lead but it looks like he's
gonna be one or two short again for the
now the third time basically although I
think Gant's had at the the last time
but couldn't form a coalition either so
when you have too many parties it can
also be very hard to do things so we
have to sort of be careful what we wish
when we've had something that has worked
pretty well for a certain amount of time
here for 200 plus years that's a pretty
good situation although we used to have
more functioning political parties but
what I would rather see generally with
the parties is I would love to see the
strong libertarians push for what they
want more in the conservative movement
that that makes sense to me because you
have the basic ideas that we kind of
believe in the Constitution so that
makes sense we should have that fight
within the party the Democratic thing as
I said before it doesn't really make
sense anymore I think if that thing
breaks down then have a socialist party
if that's what you want and have a
democratic party that maybe just stands
for slightly less big government I don't
know what it would really stand for have
a Republican Party and then if there's
some other ideas out there then have
those parties too because that's what
we're all doing online anyway right
we're all finding the ideas we like
online so the system has to sort of
change with us but the risk is and this
is why when Bernie wants to burn the
whole thing down all the time it's like
you want to be careful what you wish
were because we have things that have
existed for a long time and done really
well again they're not perfect things
and this is why all the time when I talk
about why the New York Times is so
horrible and CNN is so horrible and so
much is it's horrible it's like I just
want them to be not totally horrible but
they seemingly can't do it it's like
almost once the social justice woke is
something infects the host it just
immediately takes over it so it's a very
easy disease to catch but it's hard to
get rid of the way a virus
is and it eats away at all of these
things so what we're seeing right now
and this I think gets to Truman's
question a moment ago is is the
socialist view the end of what a big
government liberalism is and maybe that
is what it is so let Bernie do his thing
but fight it with the good ideas of
freedom and liberty and limited
government at states rights and the rest
of it from from a different perspective
so that's what I would say about that
all right here's one totally different
but definitely worth talking about what
do you think about the current
coronavirus situation okay I think one
of the things that I think just broadly
speaking is it is very hard to get
information that feels sort of sane and
non alarmist and and reliable about this
so I've been trying and I've tweeted out
a couple of times you know if you guys
have people that you trust on this that
you think are being honest about it
etcetera etc personally at the moment
because I'm so leery about clickbait and
the way everyone gins fear up all the
time I'm not super super worried at the
moment you know I've looked at I've
looked at some of the graphs and you see
some some stuff that starts looking like
a hockey stick that looks kind of scary
this is by no means we're I'm an expert
so I don't want even be alarmist or even
not alarmist in this but what I would
say in a sort of I suppose reassuring
way is that I don't think what has
happened in China is going to happen
over here of course anything could
change
I was just on I've been on a lot of
planes lately there's a lot of people
wearing masks you know when you go to a
place like San Francisco and then you
see all these homeless people everywhere
and filth all over the place and garbage
everywhere and again we see that in LA
now are these places gonna be breeding
grounds for people that are sicker to
transmit these things I suppose that's
possible right now it sounds like it's
really only deadly for elderly or really
infirmed people but that that younger
healthier people are surviving it could
it could it morph and change all these
things are possible you know what this
is where I would love to have some more
information from you guys so if you are
following some people
that you think have really sober good
honest answers on this do me a favor
email support at Rubin report calm and
we'll look about we'll look into getting
some people on the show I already have a
short list of people that I want on but
that would that would actually be very
helpful to do that alright let's jump to
the to the next Skype call guys who am I
talking to here
I'm going to talk to
Kevin Kevin do we have yet hey Kevin
how's it going pretty good you saw I'm
not seeing oh there we go got the video
alright man what's happening so much how
you doing Dave I'm good I'm good talking
to real people tell me what's better
this is CNN come on all right what do
you got for me my question is as we see
media move from cable television to like
a long podcast and format how long do
you think will be until we have our
first POTUS podcast kind of like how we
have POTUS Twitter how it's kind of the
official Twitter now do you think we'd
ever see a president host their own
podcast while serving as president to
speak directly to the American people
you know interview members of his/her
cabinet or advisers or something like
that oh man that's a great question well
we're already heading there in a lot of
ways right Ted Cruz right now is doing a
podcast with Michael Knowles I don't
know if they just ended it or not but he
was doing it for a while where they were
talking about impeachment and I think
sleeves is now doing his own solo
podcast so I think we're already seeing
and the way Trump tweets and that
everybody is on Twitter and the rest of
it I think we're already seeing that
happen you know remember back in the day
presidents until very recently I think
maybe Trump is the first one not to do
it used to give a weekly radio address I
think even Obama did it if I'm not
mistaken so doing a podcast is just sort
of the next version of that but yeah the
way that right now celebrity and and the
political machine is just colliding and
becoming one thing it's like why would
anyone at this point vote for a career
politician it's pretty hard to be a
career politician and get anything done
so I do sense we're gonna have more
Trump like people be politicians at
least the affected ones people that come
from the private sector or that for
better or worse are celebrities or
comedians or youtubers or whatever else
it is
I actually think something like that
would be pretty cool I mean imagine if
right now Trump was doing a weekly thing
where it was like each week he just
talks to a different you know
different person in his cabinet I had a
Jeep PI on who is the from the not the
CAA from the FCC CAA is my agency from
the FCC and it's like we had a great
conversation and we talked a lot about
Trump it would be really cool to hear
Trump go well this is why I hired you
this is where we agree this is where we
disagree and everything else
yeah excellent answer I think it would
make sense for some like Trump to go on
your podcast or like Rogen once a month
or something like that I think you know
he'd get elected for a third term if
he'd do something like that yeah well I
didn't know I think it's good idea
well you just freaked out you just
freaked out yeah third term Oh people
are freaking out I do think it's
possible listen I will put the stake in
the ground I believe we will get Trump
on this show before the election that
that is my belief we've been working on
it and we shall see I'd love to see it
right on man well I appreciate it thank
you all right talk to you later
yep all right let's go we got an update
for you guys the current Democratic
pledged delegate counts is 144 to Biden
101 to socialists we got 26 at blue to
judge 9 at Elizabeth Warren again the
interesting thing with Elizabeth Warren
is what she what's her move right now
right like you're done we all know
you're done I said she was done weeks
ago the question is what does she try to
extract from either Bernie or from Biden
for the support what does she go for for
that I don't know what her move is the
longer she stays in the more she hurts
Bernie right cuz her people most likely
go to Bernie so if she wants to somehow
team up with Bernie then it's like get
out now and push your people to Bernie
if you want to team up with Biden it's
also like get out now and help buy it
and get over the hump so she has a
really interesting move to make and I'm
sure there are people behind the scenes
on both campaigns trying to come up with
whatever that offer is is it VP I mean
this and this by the way is where what I
was talking about related to two Biden's
cognitive abilities and long-term health
as a 77 year old who has had health
issues who's obviously having some stuff
go on with him right now this is where
this comes into play because imagine
right now if the conversation is being
had with the Biden people saying you
know how well we need a female Biden's
old and white we all get that and that's
a problem for us because we're the party
of diversity apparently even though we
only have a couple old millionaires
running for president I mean all three
of the remaining candidates know for
including Bloomberg you got a
billionaire in three millionaires right
like you can't make this stuff up the
party of the people
party of the people as for white people
all all millionaires and billionaires
but if you're Warren or you're Biden's
campaign you could be sitting there
going alright well we want Warren
support and we know that that really
hurts Ernie
so do we offer her VP because then that
gets us a woman it can't it gets the
progressive base not to burn the whole
thing down because they kinda like her
although I think the Bernie people for
the most part are off the rails and are
gonna do it no matter what but then but
then anyone voting for Biden needs to
know that is the risk the risk is you're
still gonna get a woke progressive if he
goes the route of an Elizabeth Warren so
that's why this game is so crazy right
now and by the way I want to be very
clear I'm very excited about this I
think it's actually kind of cool we're
on earth thing a lot of stuff I think
it's fun it can be a little exhausting
and a little crazy and the gamesmanship
can be whatever but but we're actually
having a if I could be cliche for a
moment we're having a battle of ideas
often very bad ideas but we're having a
battle of ideas and I actually think
that that's that that's pretty pretty
pretty good okay let's see where we're
at here I'll go to another question via
email let's see if Bernie wins the
nomination and loses to trump what
lessons do you hope or expect the
Democrats to learn I mean here's the
problem guys and and I have been talking
about this for years at no point in the
last couple years has the progressive
movement ever said were wrong about
every anything they're wrong about
everything but they've never said we're
wrong about anything so you think about
it Trump gets voted president Donald
Trump who everybody knows if there was a
normal system right now and things
weren't wacky that I think most
Republicans would go Donald Trump
probably isn't the guy that should be
president we like the guy more like
Ronald Reagan we like someone that's a
little more statesman Lee etc etc but
this is what we got and in terms of what
he's actually doing he's doing a fine
job and he's the last guy that was gonna
fight the media and the rest of it right
if Bernie wins I don't win the
nomination but that loses to Trump I
don't think there's any evidence that
the progressives have it within them to
look in the mirror I think they've you
know as
many people have said but I think Peter
Bogosian who I've had on many times my
good buddy
I think he was the first one to say that
woke nests and social justice and
leftism in collectivism all of these bad
ideas they have become a secular
religion right these people have traded
in whatever their other belief systems
are for this really bad set of ideas and
in this set of ideas there is no
redemption narrative you can't get out
and be a good person still and that's
what keeps people in it it's like a
self-selected hostage situation so
there's no evidence along the road you
would think Oh Trump became president
should we kind of think about what we've
been saying maybe we drove too many
people to the right maybe we're doing
something wrong here but did they do it
was there ever a moment of it no it's
everything's always more proof that
they're right and that the evil system
is coming for them even more and more so
in a weird way what I think would be the
healthiest thing for America would be
like let's have the battle let's have
the old Jedi verse if battle let's have
the battle of the capitalists versus the
Socialists let's have the Trump I love
America versus Bernie I hate America
let's have it out and and then hopefully
Bernie gets crushed then finally the
good liberals wherever they've been
scattered across the galaxy after order
66 whoever still survives has can come
back to the Jedi Temple and and you know
get back to Coruscant and get some
semblance of a government going again or
get some semblance of a party a sensible
party going in that strikes me as maybe
a possibility but there's just no
evidence that anything can kill this
thing you know like Freddy Krueger you
got to bury his bones to really get rid
of them but that never works either it's
something like that it's something like
that so but the problem is that if if
Biden wins here the Socialists just keep
coming they keep coming they keep coming
and that's why I think the party has to
split because the Democrats have no
defense mechanism against it what what
the Republicans have or at least people
on the right or conservatives again
whatever you want to call that is they
can say we do not believe in any of
these ideas because we are capitalists
we believe in free market capitalism and
we believe in individual rights everyone
should be treated the same under the law
that is a very strong and then and then
for concern
they have a religious underpinning of
that and everything else okay now that
is a strong set of ideas to fight this
thing with I think but the Democrats
they the remaining there is they don't
have a strong set of ideas fight it with
oh we're liberals we like to help people
we're kind of nicer than you are but
we're a little more realistic it just
doesn't make sense
so I think this thing just has to burn
out however it is but hopefully it
doesn't burn down the the party in the
country along the same time okay let's
see what do we got here let's see
Dave you tweeted the other day from your
local polling station what was your
mindset as you went to cast the ballot
so I mentioned that oh I'm sorry that
was a question for for a Skype person
let's talk to Chris Cook guys can we get
Chris on I just jumped him on the
question
let's get Chris on and we'll all right
I'm gonna give you a minute we're gonna
talk to Chris Chris mitt you can modify
your question or I'll answer that
question sorry about that Chris my bad
all right in the meantime you know what
I'll really quickly do something else
and then you guys let me know when Chris
is ready let's see we did the Tulsi
Gabbard question the Republican Party
seems more open to libertarian ideas
since the Trump phenomenon what can we
do to further remind the electorate that
individual liberty is what makes America
great and further support candidates who
will protect those ideals in the hall of
government you know one of the things
that has sort of comfort me comforted me
about Trump let's say is that ready to
go I'll do this quick is that Rand Paul
who is the most Liberty minded person in
all of the Senate obviously right son of
Ron Paul he's a true libertarian
constantly talks about spending not just
taxes and the rest of it but actually
wants to scale back government he's
become one of trumps biggest supporters
so to me it's like if the most outspoken
libertarian likes the amount of
regulation Trump is cut likes the
foreign policy we're not getting into
extraordinary an estate or now we've
reinstituted some deterrence by killing
Soleimani we're not no one we're not
gonna remember literally in one
everyone was saying we're going to war
with Iran we're not going to war with
Iran
it was obvious then rumor net neutrality
the world's over means this endless
hysteria that they've kept us on it
burns too hot so I actually do think
there is a nice moment for libertarians
and one of the things I hear I speak at
a lot of libertarian conferences and for
a lot of libertarian groups on college
campuses
they say they keep saying oh well we
need to run a strong libertarian against
Trump
and it's like I don't think so guys like
right now you got a guy that's pretty
amenable to a lot of your ideas he's a
businessman he's a free-market guy does
he want tariffs more than you want him
probably more than you want them
probably does he want borders in ways
that perhaps some of you know the open
border libertarians which I'm not by the
way one possibly but is he mostly
getting there and that's what I would
say you know a classical liberal to me
is just a more realistic libertarian
where a libertarian is more of a
utopianist and the classical boroughs a
little more of a realistic one where I
go well we gotta have some government
Trump's sorta seems to be in kind of
something like that and on that note
let's go to Chris Chris I'm sorry I
jumped you on the question man let's see
if we get some video over there
Chris do we have you do we have
we're still working this whole system
through guys so thanks for being patient
with us we will perfect it by next time
do we have Chris
I think we lost Chris alright we're
gonna you know what come back to me
let's see if we can snag him again and
then and then we'll go from there okay
where can we go here on let me give you
a little update on things Texas you know
these numbers are just changing it just
does just I hope do we have Chris Chris
yes geez Chris all right man can you get
your video on I I do it there we go I
think you've got video it's on its way
yeah I don't see it yet but all right
maybe maybe it's coming through and I
just can't see it on my screen how you
doing man
think we lost yeah
we lose Chris guys guys I'm gonna let
you sort this out in the control room
I'm gonna keep rolling okay okay we lost
we lost Chris sorry about that
Chris hang tight let's see if we can
figure it out let's see um
oh this is this is a really interesting
question what do you think the
president's debate approach will be
towards each eye we got Chris again
let's try it again Chris are you there
I am here all right there you are I
can't see you right now but I'll trust
you tried to turn the camera on - maybe
it'll pop on so we'll see how's it going
I think we lost them again
man Skype
the Skype gremlin all right come back to
me hello people see we're on the fly
here we're gonna we're gonna perfect all
this we're actually testing out a new
system on how we can do these live calls
so I appreciate you guys bearing with us
the question that I saw here which I
think is really interesting is what do
you think the president's debate
approach will be towards each of the
rivalries Sanders Biden Bloomberg which
one be the most fun most cringe and most
trampled like approach okay so I think
in Trump's mine Biden's the guy he wants
right cuz it gets you to unearth all the
Ukraine stuff with Biden's son and it
gets him to rehash impeachment which he
won and the Democrats lost it's a little
bit more traditionally like it was
debating Hillary right you know what
you're kind of getting it's just a it's
just a standard Democrat from the
machine and that's what you're getting
and he and he would be the most
comfortable doing that I think so I
think it would be very comparable let's
say to what it was like when he debated
Hillary I think it would be very very
much like that also Trump you know for
whatever you want to say about him and
the strange way he speaks and all that
stuff it's like the guy's pretty quick
on his feet and knows how to crack a
joke and when you've got Biden befuddled
and everything else I think that would
play well to trump the Bernie one is
interesting because Bernie for all that
I don't like about him Bernie does know
his ideas right so Bernie I think would
be able to ID averse idea Trump strength
is not ideas Trump I think has a broad
sense of what he believes but I don't
think he's like a nitty gritty sort of
policy guy like I want to get in on
healthcare and talk about all the
different reasons I'm for this or that
or why I do this or that Trump likes the
idea then hires people that can massage
the idea so I think in that way Trump
Sanders then becomes a little bit more
difficult to deal with but I think
ultimately what gives Trump the major
advantage over Sanders and in many ways
the major advantage over any of the
Democrats at this point is Trump can
constantly hang his hat on I am a
capitalist I love America we have had
230 years of freedom like nowhere else
we are a good country we are a decent
country we are our moral country the
world needs us to be the leader all of
those things and and Bernie
fundamentally is unable to say good
things about America I mean he just
can't he never does he says nice things
about Sweden and Denmark and I think at
the end even if Sanders out locked him
on some policy stuff I think most people
would walk away going Trump likes
America Bernie doesn't really like
America maybe Bernie could be President
of Sweden but I kind of like him
and I'm gonna vote for the guy who likes
America so I think that makes his job
against Sanders even though on the
policy side I think it would be a little
more difficult because Sanders could get
him into a game that's not really his
game to play I think he wins there and
then the Bloomberg one I mean that's the
biggest x-factor and look Bloomberg is
sort of all the things that everyone
said Trump was everyone said Trump was
buying the boat and Trump's a
billionaire and he's buying influence
and blah blah blah and it's like he
didn't really do any of those things the
media gave him a lot of coverage and
free publicity and you know he wasn't
paying all these people to canvas
everywhere and all the rest of this
nonsense
it's like Bloomberg bought his way in so
I think Trump also the problem of
Bloomberg is he doesn't come off like a
human I mean he's incredibly stiff it's
like how did this guy even get into
politics do I again as I said earlier do
I think he's a functioning executive
what do I think he was a good mayor in
the city that I lived in New York City
yes I don't think it would even matter
about maybe he's a little bit more big
government than Trump I think it would
just come off that he's just sort of an
uncharismatic boor more than anything
else and and by the way his biggest
problem wouldn't be Trump Bloomberg's
biggest problem is that the base would
go bananas I mean the base is gonna go
bananas no matter what right because if
you go by it in the base is still gonna
go bananas but if they if the if it's
Bloomberg and the base goes all right we
didn't get it with Bernie and you guys
took out Biden and you went for the
billionaire who is a capitalist who
dared where'd I don't know you guys saw
this he wore that evil did you see that
that evil flag at the debate last week
he were an American flag at a democratic
debate I mean that's a no no it with
these things I think the base would go
crazy so I think that would make Trump's
job easier because Trump could
constantly be like your own party hates
you little Mike get off your shine box
the the party hates it so I don't know I
I see Trump's a fairly good debater he
proved it against Hillary heel he's also
willing to pull out all the stops I
think Mike would have some Bloomberg
that is would have some tricks up his
sleeve but I don't I don't see that plan
that well either all right we're at 154
Biden 103 by the way I should have
mentioned that it takes 1991 delegates
to win the nomination California
he has not been updated do we have an
update on California which is the
biggest hall in the country I think it's
what is it it's something like 300 plus
delegates in California I'm not sure so
when we we get some info on that that's
that's obviously the big fish of the
night
so we'll see about that guys should I
try Erica on Skype are we good on that
one or are we still trying to get Chris
just let me know let's see here are
we're getting some california updates as
well let's see what's that we can go to
Eric all right let's go to Eric on the
skype Eric how you doing
we're calling Eric alright now I see how
this thing's going we've got everybody
on queue and then we call them when it
works
Eric do we have yet I am here alright it
worked I'm not seeing you oh there we go
Eric how's it going hey Eric see I bet
you a couple days ago you did in San
Francisco I'm in Silicon Valley working
in tech marketing well it's it's good to
see you again Winston we had a little
impromptu Rubin report community meeting
in about 15 or 20 people showed up it
was a ball yep absolutely had a great so
this is great what you're doing here
thanks man I love the roof our community
not only interacting with you but all
the great people that we some of them
that we met in San Francisco some of the
smartest kindest you know most
insightful people that I've ever talked
to or met so my question really is about
Texas about Texas sure what the heck is
going on in Texas this is traditionally
red state and Bernie Sanders is ahead
over there so what is going on are the
California immigrants just ruining the
great state of Texas by my opinions we
need a wall around California but to
keep the people in I think ironically
you say that as someone that I just saw
you in California there's some weird
stuff here so first off you got to
remember that this is just a Democratic
primary so when you see that the base of
the Democrats are going more to the left
and more towards Bernie and socialism
and the whole thing that just may where
beware the rabid base of the energy is
that doesn't mean it's a Texas wide
phenomenon but that being said in the
Senate race the the Ted Cruz versus Beto
Senate race it was stupidly close I mean
only a couple points stopped stopped
Cruz from winning and and woulda had
Beto you know a very very far left
progressive who wants to confiscate guns
would have been the the senator the
Democratic senator
from Texas so there is some weird energy
there and even though you're joking
about the the California thing I can
tell you I think maybe we discussed this
briefly the other night over drinks that
when I travel the country in the last
year or so the amount of people that I
meet in the middle of the country that
are going Dave you got to stop the
Californians from coming here because
they leave because of the bad lefty
ideas and then they import these stupid
ideas here I hear a ton of that so I'm
sure there's some version of that
happening in Texas right now and I think
it's happening anyway you know in Utah I
think it's happening in Colorado I think
it's happening in Florida and some other
places well that's why I make the joke
about building a wall around California
the rest of the state I'm talking to
some of these or you're exchanging
messages on the Rubin report command
with with the members there and they're
saying hey enough with the California is
moving into our space and I hear that
people people in Texas all the time
because they're kind of ruining it but
you know when you look at Bernie Sanders
who is about as far left as you can get
oh forget that in American politics he
is as far left as you can get you know
my opinion is he's a communist in his
views primarily even beyond socialism
and democratic socialism however he
wants to frame it but when he's ahead in
Texas yeah makes me a little nervous
yeah I I see it and again you know you
got to just view it through the limited
print prism of a party party primary so
if you view it you through that oh man
I've been talking a lot today if you
view it through that concept then I
think it's a little more you know I you
know I'm double talking here I got my my
audio whacked out in my ear now I'm
hearing myself speak a minute later okay
let's start that over all that
everything that you said I think is
basically right but if you view it
through the prism of a party primary
where we know that the base is out of
control then the hope is that it's just
the base and the hope is that if Bernie
loses the nomination the hope is I
suppose that the moderates then modder
you know become more
and either some of them may be moved to
Trump's some of them don't vote or some
of them vote for Biden or something like
that
so you think there's no danger of Texas
going going for Bernie I don't know I
don't think there's no danger but I
don't think it's a huge danger I really
don't not yet I mean especially and look
even Biden Biden today just said this
thing about Beto it's like you're gonna
lead me on guns it's like man you want
to lose Texas quick go for the guns but
again that being said Beto did get kind
of close to Cruz for the Senate race so
you know there's a lot of things that
are just kind of upside down right now
so who knows
yeah absolutely my other question is can
you can you quote the second line of the
Declaration of Independence and if you
can't read you
go on no I mean I'm joking if you can't
should you be elected president if it's
the Bernie Bernie joke I'm sorry I Biden
no I mean you know the thing yeah we
find these truths to be self-evident
yeah and all men are created equal can
you believe it it's crazy
radical stuff all right are ecstatic all
right
Thanks all right see you soon all right
where are we at in Texas here he's
talking about Texas Texas right now 28
per twenty eight point nine Biden
twenty-three I'm sorry twenty eight
point nine Sanders twenty-three Biden
and 18 sort of Yankee new northerner
something like that and again I say this
as a lifelong New Yorker I was born in
Brooklyn I grew up in Long Island I went
to college upstate New York I lived in
New York City most of my life so I
there's a lot of good things about New
York it's easy to mock it all the time
if we have ridiculously high taxes New
York City's become a progressive
craphole because of Bill DeBlasio but it
just seems funny to me like it's hard to
picture a Texan voting for Bloomberg
cause it's like if you're gonna vote for
the moderate then why not just go in on
by it in but I guess a lot of people do
have the worries about buy it in so
there you go
California is not reporting it thank you
guys
there are 415 delegates in in California
all right guys we're gonna go for 7 more
minutes we're gonna go till 7:30 local
time and let's see what else we got
there I see some questions flying in as
I'm on the fly here let's see what's the
most effective attack the Trump campaign
could use in the upcoming election to
tear down a potential bite in Sanders
campaign I'm from Washington I'm at and
I'm absolutely bombarded at work by anti
Trump sentiment and was told recently to
stop listening to people like you and
ben shapiro in the warehouse because my
boss was upset by it so i'm so thankful
for you and Ben and Jordan and all the
amazing IDW well first off thanks thanks
for listening and thanks for your
support and all that good stuff and that
sucks that sucks that you're putting
that
I will give you some hope I told the
story I think a couple weeks ago but
maybe three months ago or so I was in
Home Depot and we were buying some
plants and I hear ben shapiro bench beer
and he started it and I'm going to
Shapiro's here Shapiro's up one aisle
over and he's talking to somebody about
something and it turned out that it was
a guy that worked at Home Depot who was
up on a forklift you know putting stock
away and he happened to be a
dark-skinned guy okay so I'm gonna
assume he was Latino I don't know for a
fact but you know if you think for all
the people that think only white racists
or something watch Shapiro or listen to
Shapiro it was not that you know it was
a blue-collar labor or guy working hard
to earn a dime who I'm guessing was
probably first or second generation
American who was probably thrilled to
have the job listening to Shapiro so I
do think good ideas are proliferating
and I'm credibly imposed about that and
I hear you it's it sucks and speaking of
being bombarded you know I don't watch
TV that often I certainly don't watch TV
during the week but on the weekend I'll
flick channels a little bit if I have a
little time and the amount of Mike
Bloomberg ads that were being hit with
the last couple days in California has
just uh and he doesn't even come off as
cool or good or happy or like anyone
likes him in that it's like you can't
even tell if they're there hit pieces on
the guy and the the licking of the
fingers thing again today you saw that
he's eating the pizza he's licking his
fingers he touches the spicket at the
communal coffee thing it's like man you
are out of touch you are out of touch
okay let's see guys should we jump to
Andrew on on skype what's that we're
we're calling Andrew on skype all right
let's talk to Andrew on skype hey Dave
hello Andrew in Grand Rapids how you
doing man
I'm good how are you Dave I'm doing well
I think your remember is gonna kick in
insect there you go all right hey how's
it going man good good very professional
headphone situation I tell you what man
come prepared very good well my man
so one thing that I asked a question
about originally about your VP thoughts
and all that but as you were talking a
lot more about VP things I got to
thinking more about how people will just
say things like a lot of the candidates
have said just out not lies and there's
no accountability whatsoever and the
closest thing I can see is something
that's accountable or some kind of
repercussions for saying something that
isn't true is kind of the wokes cold
cancel culture where there's actually
people losing job like Chris Matthews
just lost his job because because he
said something but it's it's kind of its
worst version of accountability and I'm
wondering about your thoughts about like
okay if we're gonna have candidates that
are not octogenarian socialists and
people who are you know not the worst in
the bottom of the barrel like I think
that it's important that we get the
culture right and I'm wondering how do
we get it so that these kind of slippery
politicians don't just say whatever they
want to say and have nothing there's
there's no repercussions what do you
thought so no oh man it that's such a
good question and it's interesting that
you brought Chris Matthews into it
because I have no particular feelings
one way or another towards Chris
Matthews he's just a cable news guy I
met him briefly once at a debate a
couple years ago you know MSNBC guy you
sort of get what you get but he was
never fully woke and that's the funny
thing I think with a lot of these guys
that are not fully woke they think if
they're just woke enough that it'll
ultimate that it buys them protection
but what they don't realize they're just
buys you a certain amount of time it
doesn't really buy you protection
because there's a protection racket
going but the second you really step
over the line they will take you out and
that's why they took him out I mean the
idea that he resigned from MSNBC in the
middle of the craziest election ever the
guy who lives for this absolutely lives
for this
is crazy I will tell you one one funny
Chris Matthews Matthews thing and then
I'll answer your question specifically
maybe like eight or nine years ago when
I lived in New York City it was a Sunday
afternoon I was out with my ten friends
we're at a Mexican joint at like two
o'clock drinking margaritas everybody's
wasted it's like 2 o'clock beautiful day
out on the on the Upper West so we're
sitting outside chris matthews walks by
and i've always been a political junkie
although i wasn't doing a politics show
at the time and I was like yo hardball
you want to join us and he just looked
at me like you know he's got that
laughter ah laughs and then he just
walked away in answer to your question
though honestly this is gonna sound a
little corny but what I really believe
the honest answer is of how do we get
more accountability out of these guys is
that we need more of what I would say is
the sort of Jordan Peterson like message
out there and that's why I'm actually
really hopeful you know I spent you know
I spent a year plus on tour with the guy
and a hundred plus stops and 20
countries and everything and I saw
people bettering themselves every day
and truly I bettered myself through the
course of that I'm not perfect but I
know it helped me get on a path that I
want to be on that I'm on now
and I think the more that you know young
guys like you and and people they're
watching all of these shows the more
that you believe in personal
responsibility the more that we all like
kind of get our lives right then we
could fix the system right like that's
the whole point why are you cleaning
your room you're cleaning your room
because everyone wants to clean the
world first clean your room first and
then eventually enough people will
trickle up through the system where you
know Bernie and the Socialists they want
this top-down thing they know what's
right for you and they'll tell you
what's right and that's just the reverse
oh I hope you know that woman behind you
otherwise we get a real viral moment
here we're doing our taxes right now so
we're doing taxes yeah well with the
super Super Tuesday in taxes so it's all
government all day you're gonna be an an
cap by the end of the day but but in any
event I think really that is what the
answer is like it's not like the most
satisfying answer because it's like oh
it's on you to fix it by like whatever
you do in your life like I pretty sure
if
we all start being the best versions of
ourselves somehow and living with some
degree of honor and integrity and doing
the best work we can that we can force
the change up I think that's really it's
the best I got
yeah I agree and I think that it's not
enough to just have like oh what's a
better candidate or like oh man one of
these good qualities like it starts way
before that and it and I think that's
why Jordan Peterson's so popular because
he looks beyond just the the the premise
that it has to be somebody's personality
that that you know has a savior complex
you know it's like a lot of people on
the one hand talk about how awful
politicians are but then for some reason
we look to them to be our moral leaders
and and these these kind of moral yeah
like leaders and people who are going to
change the culture and like save us from
this and really that's that's they're
just reacting to us which I think not a
lot of people understand so well yeah
one of the things when I when I woke up
from being a progressive it was like
they were always screaming about how
corrupt everybody is how evil everybody
is and how awful government is and their
answer was to always give it more power
but we just have them there guys in it
meaning their guys are good and moral
and decent and they'll do all the right
things but everybody else who believes
the different thing those are the real
bad guys and whatever and that's really
why I came around to believing in
personal responsibility and and all the
other stuff that I always talk about I
don't know if you know this but my tribe
is better than your tribe so when my
tribe takes over it's it's way better
but your tribes not as good you're not
gonna believe this but I think my tribe
is better and way better I'll do it much
better and that's our you're objectively
wrong and I'm all right man good talking
to you thanks for the support
Oh awesome oh yeah I was gonna say I'll
throw in the VIP thing but I guess you
did it already SLC and Grand Rapids you
lemon all right right on yeah all right
guys it is 7:30 to and
we do not have a California update where
@ 28.9 in texas for sanders 23.2 so that
whatever that percentage is going to
shake out it's obviously not going to
move too much so I will just give you
the final delegate count that as I have
it right now although it's not the final
of the night obviously 163 Bernie sorry
163 Joe you know what's funny I'm doing
this on my iPad here and my guys are
giving me information on the fly so you
can see it moving at different times but
all i have when i see biden and bernie
is i have two tiny little pictures of
old men so when i look at it i don't see
their names i just see an old man's head
because that's what they've left us with
so it is biden with 163 bernie 109 and
again Budaj Ed's got the 26 but he's
done and Warren has got nine but she's
done she has to figure out what she
wants to do so I'll leave you guys with
this I think a couple interesting things
will happen over the next couple days
will kind of see now does Obama finally
make a move and endorsed by and as
Hillary actually knew anything are they
all still hedging their bets in case
Biden flames out do these guys Biden and
Bernie because of their age have to
announce VP candidates early does does
Bernie have to do something to suddenly
get a little momentum back do the Bernie
people go completely bananas right now
because now they're losing and they're
they're pretty sore losers they like
winning everyone likes winning but they
really want to burn the thing down if
they're not winning there's a lot of
questions that remain to be seen don't
get too crazy about it just live your
life however you can check in when you
can care about it but don't let it
dominate you be part of the system as
much as you can and pardon I shouldn't
say the system be part of the process as
much as you can and I'll keep doing this
and I hope you guys will keep joining
we'll work out these bugs this was
really a first live test run-through and
we were just changing some stuff in the
studio so we'll have this perfected next
time I promise you and maybe we'll start
doing a live calling thing more often I
think it's actually a really cool way of
connecting with you guys and I often
learn
more from you guys when I meet you at on
the street or at events than I do from
some of the people that I have in here
and even just for the five or six people
that I talk to tonight it was like those
are pretty interesting questions you
know that's that's good stuff that's not
just the generic stuff that you're gonna
see in other places so anyway I thank
you guys and Super Tuesday man we'll see
what we wake up to